well i've seen every single episode of
grey's anatomy girl so i have some
questions
every single one how many episodes have
been i think what like three years in
like three i think we're in
we're in the 300s somewhere in there
really yes i'm i'm committed i'm
i don't even know if i've seen every
single one i also discovered not that
anyone else cares but we actually have
the exact same birthday
me and you yeah december 15th i don't
want to say the year but yeah the exact
same day like senior year
[Music]
so season 17 kindle i mean this has put
viewers less viewers through the ringer
just not only with the story lines but
the circumstances how we didn't know if
you guys would be coming back
yeah so like when did you guys finally
know that you were coming back for
another she's like was it after you shot
the finale
oh you mean coming back for season 18.
yeah yes
okay um i had already
left shooting i was done with the season
and we were still not picked up
that's we heard after maybe like the
last couple days of shooting but i was
personally done so i didn't know
and we have our trailers on set and i
was like should i be cleaning out my
should there be a moving van like what's
going on i couldn't find out any
information
and then when we were finally picked up
i was really excited but truly we did
not know it wasn't just something we
were all saying like
we truly did not know right like how did
you find out that you're coming back for
next season
we've i i swear i think i read it online
i'm not even i don't think anyone made a
call to me
i think i read on like deadline
seriously
so what was it like the mood on set like
not annoying like you're shooting things
like that
it was really difficult because yeah
what was hard about this season is that
usually we have some idea of what
happens in the finale
and like oh there's going to be an
explosion there's going to be
a tornado whatever it is right and then
this year
silence and like a week before we even
started shooting there was still no
script out and
i think that we were all wondering like
is this the finale and we just haven't
been told and they're gonna
be like hey here's the script and you're
all dead or whatever's good
um so that was
a really wild end to the season um
but then our you know but we shot our
finale we are coming back and there's
lots of incredible things happening in
it
and thankfully we're not all dead right
yes
not wiping everyone out no well i saw
your photo that you posted in the pink
scrubs how did that feel
i'm so excited about the pink scrubs
they made me really happy
it was like a moment for me i i remember
getting to
getting to work and and not remembering
that i was changing into the pink and i
did like this very dramatic like gasp
when i opened my costume class i was
like oh
thank you and i was like oh my gosh it
like made me really happy i love her in
pink because
i secretly love the pink yeah yeah
what's the bit like this journey that
joe's been on this season like making
this career change it's interesting
because
at the beginning of the season we have
meetings where they kind of tease a
little bit like we think this is what's
going to happen with joe and so
i had heard that she might make the
career change but things changed all the
time so i was crossing my
fingers i just think it's a really nice
organic move for her because i think
that
things you know for everybody during
covert we were made to
sit and sort of like really think about
our day-to-day life and what happiness
is and what it means to us and all these
different things i think that she really
had the time to sit during
her covet experience and figure out what
would bring her joy and she was
searching for it and she found it
so i think it's a really great
journey that she's been on and i i like
that she's selfishly
thinking for herself right and then the
beginning of the season we had like the
friends with benefits thing
with jackson first off were you
surprised that they wrote that
um i had well well
we had shot that actually a lot of that
footage at the begi
at the end of last year oh really and
then we shut down for coven
and so it got reworked in a way um when
i was initially told about it back then
i was shocked
um and then you know
this season was it was i have to tell
you i haven't spoken about this yet but
it was like the funniest way to film
with anybody like any kind of like sexy
stuff because
there was a point when we knew that
jesse was leaving and so they definitely
wanted
not to be romantic they wanted to be a
friends with benefit situation so they
would yell at us like i've never been
yelled at like on set being like
no chemistry less chemistry and so we
would joke we would like do a scene
and jesse would be like was that it was
that enough lack of chemistry for you so
it was like a very strange
thing like usually you're having to like
give a lot of chemistry in your scene so
it was it was really fun to film i mean
i'm sad that he left because i would
have liked to have maybe seen
if it could have gone further and what
you know what they could have been like
together
possibly dating at some point um because
i just think they're an interesting
combination
but um but i'm glad she had it she had
fun
she needed it right yeah what's that
like like to
go through that process of cast members
leaving because obviously you've been
there for several years now and several
cast members are left so what's that
process like
say goodbye to these people i mean i
think on a show that's like been on the
air for this many seasons you know
there's no way that you're not gonna get
probably a considerable amount of like
cast members coming but the great coming
and leaving but
the great thing about our show is the
influx of new actors that we get on our
show
that also bring you know fresh new blood
and ideas and story to our world so
um i definitely will miss you know
giacomo
and and greg german who also left this
season
um i'm going to miss some you know greg
girvin's a scene stealer he's so funny
and giacomo is incredible um and he
directed his first episode this season
so hopefully he'll be back to maybe
direct something next season
and jesse too um but you you kind of get
used to it and you expect that at some
point you're going to see more people go
but then there's the excitement always
of new people coming in too
right the alex thing still hurts
i know do you talk to justin at all like
do you keep in touch at all with justin
i haven't talked to him i feel like i
haven't talked to anybody during coleman
that's true yeah i covered bubble and
like when i see people i'm just excited
like wave at random strangers i feel
like i'm like
a weirdo at this point of after krovitz
yeah
so i know there's been like a little bit
of talk of like
possible spin-offs down the line like
once grey's anatomy has ended
would you be open that would you want to
see joe like say they say we're gonna
send joe to another hospital
starting your series like would you be
up for that
um let me think i mean i don't think
that you can ever say
no to anything and i think it would
definitely depend on
um where they would want the character
to go and what kind of story
it would it would you know they would be
doing um
but you can't say no to anything who
knows we'll see
yeah so what can you tease about the
finale which is now the season finale
just thank god the season five okay so
the season finale
is sometimes we just have here's how i
describe it sometimes we have like
one big thing that will happen and this
was like
15 big things happening in a tiny script
in fact there was
so much material so many crazy well
things happening that we were gonna
originally go over in days shooting and
we had to just do longer filming days to
make up
um so we have a wedding happening in our
finale
we have meredith gray taking on a
new role in the hospital which is really
exciting
um we have relationships shifting
and we gotta write
makes two really big decisions in the
finale
you know what i think are you not going
to tell me i think she's going to adopt
that baby
joe i think she's going to i'm sure
you're not going to tell me
well well in the episode we just watched
she got rejected
oh okay oh is that that maybe that's
this that's tonight
yes that's right you're keeping track of
this better than mine
tonight she gets her adoption
application got rejected
so if she you know i think that it's
she's
the end of the this episode you know
it's completely devastating for her so
going into the next episode she's sort
of reworking her mind and thinking about
like
what she needs to do next man can't wait
to see that i also
reading that you want to be on bridgeton
yes darling i would love to members
have you thought this morning ready for
my cool set
rhimes yes of course i would i think
i've tweeted that i would like be a maid
in the background or something like that
i will do anything
please watch that that's amazing
now how is how's home life going like
you know give birth to lucas i don't
have a life
is that how's the home setting the house
yeah
i haven't i have two children in the
pandemic
like i said i don't talk to anybody i
still don't go out
um there's not i feel like there's when
you have a new baby i feel like there's
there's not a lot that you're doing
you're just surviving and trying to
trying to sleep when possible
right how's hayden with lucas
hayden is really cute with lucas she's
they they they already have like their
kid he's only nine months and they have
like a kid language between the two of
them going on
like already like they giggle together
and i'm like i'm not in on this inside
joke that's happening already
um but no they're really adorable and i
was worried because when another kid
comes along you're kind of worried that
they're gonna
maybe you know be jealous or something
but there's none of that happening we've
been very lucky and she's
really cute with him that's good do you
figure out any kind of way to have alone
time
like literally by myself when i take a
bath
closet or something yeah sometimes like
find a closet and that's my alone
um i um yeah i do we've just you know in
los angeles we've just started to open
up
and so my husband and i have been we
literally just went out for our first
like
dinner together like maybe a week ago
and i mean
we've we're taking it very slow so we're
trying to find those moments now
where we have that alone time yeah
you